if I could have your attention please if
Paul Bracken if not me if Paul Bracken
could have your attention we want to
welcome him coming to columbia coming
back to columbia was a columbia
undergrad he graduated from the
engineering school here and so he's I
hope anyway happy to be back so to
welcome Paul let me just say a couple of
things about what he's done since then
he's done a lot he's now a professor at
Yale in school management and political
science as well he wrote one of the
first books about nuclear command and
control since then he's written books
like fire in the East about the rise of
military power and missiles and nuclear
weapons in in Asia and how that was
changing the world balance of power more
recently has been working on new
projects for having to do with applying
risk analysis and international security
he also works and things like applying
techniques of net assessment and other
kinds of forecasting so for all these
reasons we're really happy to have them
here because this program after all is
not just about history it's also about
what that history helps us in thinking
about the future so tonight is going to
be talking to us about the second
nuclear age so no further ado let me
turn things over to Paul thank you for
coming thank you thank you very much
Matt it's really a deep honor to come
back here and to be standing in the
front of the room rather than taking
notes here and when I was at Columbia it
was a very very different environment
and I don't want to if anybody wants to
hear old legs or old lines on about the
1960s and early 70s and
do a couple people who didn't make it
through as they say well me just one
other anecdote about how this I got out
of here in 1971 with an engineering
degree and had no idea what I wanted to
do with my life and so so I worked it is
a busboy for a while in Philadelphia but
then I saw an ad in The Washington Post
that said interesting national security
were engineering background 10 years asw
experience required so I sent my resume
in to the younger people in the audience
there was a time when you had paper
resumes and mailed them into company
long since gone so to my amazement I got
a job interview in rosslyn virginia and
they guy interviewed me Incans leases
you have ten years asw experience
because i was 22 maybe 23 and I said
well I don't really know because I don't
know what the letters asw stand for who
knows what is W stands for okay it
stands for anti-submarine warfare and so
amazingly enough they needed a junior
person and I got this job because of my
a buell analogy i'm sure and i spent the
first couple of months looking at the
tape soviet nuclear weapon firing
submarines up around Greenland united
kingdom iceland gap we would somehow get
these tapes of what they were doing and
conversations and strange languages like
russian and we would analyze them at
this company and a little bit later i
got into a project this was still in the
first year there's a lesson I want to
get across here
to look at back in the Cold War days we
we looked at I'm not kidding the role of
urban sprawl in Western Europe to stop
the Warsaw Pact armies like blowing up
buildings to drop them on the autobahns
to slow down the Russian tanks and to do
this work we had I had to go down to
Fort Benning Fort Belvoir and to
Aberdeen Proving Grounds and take every
weapon in the u.s. arsenal and blow up
buildings to see what happened you know
I mean I don't know how you feel the
young men in the audience but to be 23
years old and go to work and pull the
lanyard on a 155 and blow up and
demolish a building this was the best
job I have ever had if I often think of
this when i'm leaving a faculty meeting
at yale now 155 would be really useful
to set the record straight but the
lesson here for the younger people in
the audience is all sorts of things will
happen to you in your careers that you
can't possibly anticipate and if you see
an advantage an opportunity that looks
interesting just take it and all sorts
of interesting things will complement
you know I guess what they say graduates
and speeches follow your passion okay
let me turn to the subject at hand I
have a book which I've completed should
be coming out early next year don't have
a publisher yet but we're getting me I
don't I give you the big picture points
of this thing and then we can have a
conversation to flesh in the details or
I'd love to get your comments and
questions on really any aspect of it
because I learn all the time as I get
older I realize how much you never stop
needing to learn and actually least in
my case actually learning
I think the pictures of the future that
the much of the academic establishment
has think tanks have planning agencies
in the inside the Washington Beltway
outside the Washington Beltway but
government has are too rosy and I don't
think they realize just how bad things
can get as a consequence of the spread
of the atomic bomb my view is that I
don't know who's going to get the bomb
in future years I can imagine a wide
range of possibilities Iran Saudi Arabia
I don't really know my ability to
predict that isn't any better than yours
but I do know one thing I there's one
scenario about who gets the bomb that I
can't imagine and that's nuclear
disarmament far from it my view is that
the nuclear weapons are becoming more
deeply embedded in international
relations just about than they have ever
been it's true that we don't have these
super-sized Arsenal's as we had in the
cold war and we should thank our lucky
stars for that whatever happens in this
second nuclear age this is an age where
many countries 10 12 or more have the
bomb possibly terrorist groups do a real
nightmare but whatever happens in that
world it's it's not going to be as bad
as what could have happened in the first
nuclear age which is the Cold War it
trust me I have a background in physics
and engineering if one percent of those
Arsenal's had ever gone off in the Cold
War you would there is no words that
could possibly describe what would have
happened it's bad but it ain't that bad
what's bad now though is the defining
feature of a second nuclear age and that
is you have multiple decision-making
centers which makes it really changes
the game profoundly but far from moving
toward a world where you are eliminating
the bomb I think it's going in the
opposite direction where nuclear weapons
is all that some of these countries have
for their security and their status in
peacetime in situations that have
nothing whatsoever to do with crises yet
alone nuclear Wars we're chatting
earlier and just a one little fact here
is there's nine nuclear weapons States
in the world today eight of them have
spent billions of dollars to modernize
their nuclear arsenals maybe this does
or doesn't mean the US should follow
suit but it ought to mean something and
the United States is the only country
it's number nine it's the only country
that is not modernizing its nuclear
forces we get into a discussion of
whether we should or we shouldn't I
don't think well that's not my point my
point is that there's a broad macro
trend and nuclear weapons are becoming
more embedded in international affairs I
see no possibility in the foreseeable
future of a global zero I say that with
regret of which there were I am one of
the biggest supporters of global zero if
you're an American looking at american
national interests I don't see how you
couldn't but my problem is that other
countries like Russia China India see
that also and conclude that this is a
world which it's even it's much worse
from their point of view because it
gives conventional advantages to the
United States so my big point is that we
are entering a second nuclear Asian we
don't realize how bad it could get I
would say that this this subject of what
sort of where the world is going in a
macro sense we could look at it with a
number of different frameworks one
framework which I find popular in
political science and public policy is
the optimism pessimism framework is the
glass half full or is the glass half
empty I will my own view and we can have
a discussion about this this is not a
particularly useful debate if you were
to go back historically there are many
instances when for
a variety of reasons different sides
including the United States exaggerated
the threat in general and it also
exaggerated the spread of the atomic
bomb President Kennedy did say that by
the I don't have the numbers in front of
me but you've probably all heard it that
by the early 60s so by the early 1980s
there'd be something like 25 nuclear
weapons countries and that didn't come
close to happening if you look into
where he got that estimate where that
came from it came from a DoD estimate
which you can pull off of the web which
was much more conservative much more of
the view that there wouldn't be that
many countries by the early 1980s okay
but the point I would make is really and
I could give many other examples of the
bomb if you take WMD to be the spread of
the bomb a surrogate for chemical
weapons we believed that the United the
US government believed that Saddam
Hussein would have some chemical weapons
I know a lot of these people and I
believe that they believe that they
would find not nuclear weapons but some
chemical weapons they really did this
was in my view not concocted out of
whole cloth we can argue that but the
situation looking forward is different
in a number of fundamental ways to
compare the situation today to 1963 or
1973 you have today vast huge
bureaucratic military-industrial
complexes in North Korea India Pakistan
now Iran certainly in China that have
tremendous momentum behind them you are
going to have in my view or at least you
have to consider the scenarios where you
have direct economic stakes and
incentives to perpetuate these
bureaucracies increasingly a large
fraction of which are devoted to nuclear
weapons you have the possibility for
opportunistic hustling strategists to
use it to climb to the top of their
government
agencies or higher office you have a
globalization force in the world today
which is pulling countries apart
nationalism is needed to pull them
together and the atomic bomb I will
argue has a lot to do with nationalism
so I would accept this fact that the
optimism pessimism debate it was a
useful way to look at it in the past I
don't think to take the fact that the
u.s. overestimated the spread of the
bomb in the past I don't think that's a
persuasive argument looking for the
future okay now what should what are
some other features of this this this
new era which I'm calling a second
nuclear age all I mean by that is that
many countries will have the bomb and
this will have a a deep and in some
cases decisive impact on their
international security relations with
each other and with the future design of
their own strategic postures so for
example virtually all the armies I can
think about in Asia now are being cut
back and shrunk resources are being
pulled for those and put into higher
technology areas that's one example so
it's going to have an impact on
civil-military relations as it did in
the United States and the old Soviet
Union it's my view that in as we go into
this era that the problems will not be
we need to switch our frameworks I
mentioned optimism pessimism the other
framework which is predominant in the
United States is of course nuclear
non-proliferation built around the NPT
the non-proliferation treaty of 1970 but
it has many other features and people
are talking about extending this treaty
I'm a big sib i am a big supporter of
the NPT I think we should keep it I
think we have to change frameworks to go
beyond it to get into questions about
managing our way into the second look
through a second nuclear age we have to
look at coercion and we have to look at
escalation not exclusive
Lee nuclear non-proliferation just to be
clear here I think it would be better if
we didn't if nuclear non-proliferation
did work okay and that we didn't have to
face these problems it is now well
beyond the point where we can get away
with that exclusively so the question is
there are better and worse ways to get
through a second nuclear age just like
there was the first nuclear age we tend
to have this view of the Cold War first
nuclear age that it was some kind of an
all-out arms race let me tell you that
the first nuclear age the Cold War could
have been far worse than it was there
was extraordinarily moderated behavior
the United States was not involved in an
arms race ever in the cold war in my
view it was at most it's certain years
of intense sour relations with Moscow
and arms walk we were never spending for
one year we spent ten percent of the gdp
most of the time it was more like five
or six percent of the gdp dramatically
dropping on the latter parts of the Cold
War so any competition can be intense
less intense any competition can be
reckless and dangerous or prudent and
conservative my plea what my book is
about is shifting a focus so we pursue
the safer prudent moderate paths as best
we can divine them in advance rather
than the other ones which are reckless
and dangerous I would further say that
if we don't think about these things
beforehand we're not going to discern
what these safer paths might be that's
my argument in a nutshell to illustrate
some sort of additional features of this
if you were to look at the political
science public policy security file
see literature you would find a literate
you would find two gigantic collections
of books one is on nuclear
non-proliferation and I'll include all
the late related work on regime theory
which establishes global regimes against
this or that for this or that taking
place the other stream of literature
there actually is considerable
literature on deterrence post Cold War
look how do you deter Iran and this gets
into this whole subject of what's
happening today in Washington of US
policy morphing before our very eyes
from nuclear non-proliferation to
containment all right you'd find this
these huge literature's but you would
find it most one or two books on
escalation if that sounds provocative
let's say you'd find one or two books at
most on escalation and de-escalation it
just might be important how we deal with
other countries or how they deal with
each other say Israel and Iran can they
form a deterrent relationship I argue
that you cannot intelligently address
that question without also including
escalation of each against the other and
how that would involve the United States
so there's huge tranches of literature
which were well developed in the Cold
War which suggest topics that we need to
study again for a second nuclear age
closely related this is the whole
subject of how what does a strategic
posture for the United States look like
what does a strategic posture for China
look like how are we even using the term
strategic posture okay if one steps back
and look it's at the technological
revolution going on in the world today
you find a revolution in military fields
at least as great as went on in the
1950s and the 1960s it is different from
that era so for example there's
strike if you can find a target you can
pretty well kill it today with a
conventional weapon there is cyber
attack using information warfare attacks
to do all kinds of things the cyber
attack community and its really growing
quickly it's a growth business in
Washington DC that's for sure doesn't
look at the question of the relationship
of cyber attack to nuclear weapons when
I wrote my book the first book on
command and control of nuclear forces
one of the arguments that it made was if
you actually have to take out another
side in a military strike the
intelligent course of behavior both
looking at it is it from a scientific
point of view and also my belief as to
what countries would actually do what
their militaries would tell their
civilians is to go for a head shot to go
for a command structure attack as the
rational course of behavior back then we
didn't really have cyber warfare attacks
which could paralyze a command and
control system for a number of hours
while missiles conventional or perhaps
nuclear came in I can't find a single
paper on this and it seems to me i'm not
advocating it as a strategy i want to
emphasize but as as scholars of this
subject we need to step back and see
does this look attractive to other
countries enemies as well as allies
because one of the other insights that
falls out of this if you think about it
for five minutes is that in a multipolar
nuclear world nuclear allies could be
just as dangerous as nuclear opponents
okay so let me just sort of briefly go
over a couple of regents here we want to
want to preserve as much time as we can
for conversation let's go from west to
east what's going on like in the Middle
East just something and here I'm not I'm
not going to I don't want to get into
you know what the mullahs might do but
just what's going on in terms of the
dynamics of the region the dynamic
dynamics of the region is that Israel
built a nuclear force which was designed
for use its own future distant point in
an environment where there nobody else
had long-range missiles and nobody else
had nuclear weapons in the region the
big enemy of the Israeli nuclear force
was the reconnaissance satellite which
could take a photograph of one of her
nuclear Birds missiles or airplanes and
all of the political trouble that that
would cause back in the 1980s or early
1990s that world doesn't exist anymore
you'd have to be I mean I don't so
optimistic about the future if you
didn't consider if you were an Israeli
planner and you didn't consider what's
it going to be like to live in a world
where Iran has 10 or 20 nuclear missiles
mobile launch missiles that can reach
Israel what I'm saying is Israel's going
to have to shift her deterrent to see
this is this is going to happen for
reasons of elementary operations
research as much as it is for reasons of
political science it probably means by
my calculations Israel's going to need
more nuclear weapons of different sizes
and shapes and structures you may have
seen that last summer she put a dolphin
class submarine through the Suez Canal
with the permission of the Egyptian
government almost surely to be a signal
to Iran all right now the dolphin
submarine is reported to have nuclear
warheads aboard it I don't know whether
they will or they won't it doesn't
matter what matters is that nuclear
signaling of a kind that went on in the
first nuclear age isn't a hypothetical
possibility it is already happening in
the second nuclear age denying it
doesn't make it go away
going to the sort of South Asia area the
forces of India and Pakistan are growing
Pakistan as you know if you if you're
doing research in this field is building
a very significant plutonium complex for
reprocessing to supplement her uranium
bombs and why do you want plutonium
weapons if you have uranium weapons well
it turns out that the engineering behind
these things is that you quilt onium is
easier to work with for odd shaped
warheads of a kind that you would put on
anti-ship missiles at sea Pakistan is
set to move a significant fraction of
her force to see almost surely it seems
well almost surely that a scenario which
ought to be considered is an attempt to
surround India India is doing likewise
as you know she has a nuclear weapon
firing submarine which we understand at
the moment has no nuclear weapons aboard
but it's only a matter of time it seems
to be where the scenario of a nuclear
arms race in the Indian Ocean between
India and Pakistan it's going to be
something that's going to have to be
managed by the United States we will
have to inject some intelligent opinion
into this we could urge them not to do
it I personally have done that in 1998
when Indian when India under Prime
Minister bajpai detonated the main ein
teen 98 surprise shots I wrote him a
letter and I sent it to the Indian
ambassador in Washington DC dear mr. vag
pie you should take that money that
you're spending on nuclear forces and
spend it on hospitals on education and
roads I've been to India recently and
let me emphasize the roads because
there's a real problem here and I got
back at very nice reply from not from
him but from the Ambassador looked very
much like a form letter like a form
rejection letter from graduate school or
something dear professor Bracken we owe
Prime Minister bajpai always values your
opinions
I make sure he gets this information I'm
sure he'll put it into his calculus of
what he does all right what is the role
of the u.s. Navy going to be what is the
role of confidence-building measures
what is the what is arms control going
to look like when there's an arms race
in the Indian Ocean or we continue to
get by with getting out of soap axons
and say don't do it like the Catholic
priests said about child abuse in the
Catholic Church ignoring it as it built
up I think we are really in a very much
in to do in a different world finally in
East Asia you have the Chinese
modernization and it is very it's just
very impressive I mean China as you know
is building Road mobile missiles the DF
30 ones which is going to give China a
much more agile quick reacting nuclear
force I mean I can remember people that
would always say China has a minimum
deterrent the term minimum deterrent
comes from the US Navy in the 1950s it
is an invented term okay in the United
States it's never been acknowledged by
China and China never had a minimum to
tear it is used here minimo deterrent
for the just so we're on the same sheet
of paper is a force that can survive a
first strike but you and retaliate
against the person who fires it but you
don't need many of them and it's offered
as an alternative to the kind of sick
level of over armament that the
superpowers engaged in where you had
each side with I don't even like i
stopped counting after thirty five
thousand nuclear warheads it was
completely insane but we're here to look
at the second nuclear age not the first
so China never had a survivable nuclear
force she will and the Chinese will have
an ability to nuclear eyes if you will
any crisis
I'm not saying she will the capability
that she will will be noticed by the
United States in addition China has a
significant precision strike force of
800 plus missiles that she's building up
as of 2010 it's going up every three
months there's new deployments and these
are conventional warheads they many
people argue can target us surface ships
in the western Pacific leading to very
interesting escalation dynamics in the
western Pacific and very interesting
political implications for countries
like South Korea Japan Australia and
South East Asia which I think we need a
lot more work thinking about okay I'm
not here to to depress you I'm here to
drive home the first point I made which
is these Rosie scenarios that I see in
the quadrennial defense review inside
the beltway think tanks university
studies I think greatly underestimate
how bad things could get and that we
need to think about those things not
just nuclear non-proliferation the way
I'd put it this way current US policy is
to emphasize nuclear non-proliferation
to the exclusion of almost anything else
as I go to Washington I can see this
morph before my very eyes into
containment it's very striking about its
yes we don't accept the Iranian our
north korean nuclear weapons but what
are we going to do about them so we will
shift to a containment policy and you
know what about this containment policy
for the next few years it will be a
spectacular success it will be a
spectacular success just as
non-proliferation policy was a
spectacular success in the 1970s saved
for the 1974 India shots because
anything would work over the next few
years when you only have a handful of
nuclear weapons those countries are
probably not going to want to take many
risks and they're not going to be
challenged so we're an environment where
almost any policy would work
what does it mean to work when we have a
policy we have to ask the question will
it work when there's no stresses on it
and then we have to ask how will it work
when it's being stressed what would a
missile crisis look like between Israel
and Iran what would be the dynamics of
that so what I think is happening what
what should happen and frankly what will
happen is that we have this
non-proliferation and containment
morphing into containment on one column
where we need to go is to think about
some aspects of dynamics and instability
so I see dynamics by which I mean that
these systems can change and take on a
very different trajectory in a short
period of time we need to ask whether or
not fear and prudence which were the
governing mechanisms of the Cold War are
likely to be as effective in India
Pakistan or in the Middle East and as
far as the other feature of this new era
that I think when you look at
instability this just opens up a whole
raft of questions about the relationship
of conventional forces to nuclear forces
so in conclusion I think we are entering
a nuclear a second nuclear age I think
the we need to emphasize its dynamics
and it's instabilities in order to get
manage our way through it as best we can
and the final point I would make is that
the greatest source of concern for me is
stepping back from the rivalries and the
competitiveness looking at this just as
a global structural problem it's the end
of the monopoly of new over nuclear
weapons by major powers is that what
we're witnessing today this is like a
monopolistic industry where two players
controlled it and yes other players
could come in but their major powers
what we're seeing today and have for the
past ten years or so
is minor powers secondary powers are
also getting the bomb you know Iran's
Korea's frankly Israel and that this has
really deep structural implications for
world order for some time to come so
those are my thoughts and the sort of
the core arguments of the book I'd be
happy to go into any details issues we
haven't brought up or other aspects of
this what I'm sure promises to be a very
interesting conversation so thank you
very much so I'd like to ask the first
question but if you have questions
please come up to the microphone so when
earlier you mentioned that when you look
back Kennedy's prediction which as it
turns out was as I said overstating
Defense Department's own estimate of the
extent of proliferation the rapidity of
proliferation sure you said that just
because they were wrong then doesn't
mean that we're likely to overestimate
proliferation now can we learn something
from mistakes and forecasting
proliferation oh yeah how's the can you
hear me okay here can you all right yeah
I think we can learn a lot we can learn
a lot about overestimation and under
estimation we can learn a lot about the
Cold War because the lessons of the Cold
War it's really hard to find anybody
who's written an article or book called
lessons of the Cold War that isn't like
very normative but let me come to your
your question Matt yeah I think there's
a what this shows is is really
fascinating to me it's the tendency of
leaders and this is a lesson of the Cold
War not to understand their own forces
of their own bureaucracy President
Kennedy had no basis from any DoD study
yet he made this exaggerated for
cast you'll find that strikes me is
related that if you look at the Cuban
Missile Crisis and what Kennedy said he
it turns out that he had just signed off
on the revised nuclear strike plans for
the United States for the Strategic Air
Command of a kind that there's been a
lot of recently Declassified scholarship
on and these were drawn off by the Air
Force and they argued for different
packages of forces so you didn't
escalate by hitting Russian cities at
the outset so he signs this thing
literally within days he goes on TV and
overturns his own doctrine the notion
that we had a single stable doctrine or
that leaders understood their own forces
and whether estimating future threat
environments or tomorrow morning's
threat environments to not be sustained
when you look at the Cold War the way
this is put is that there's a one couple
ways to put one is technology and the
doctrinal lag technology races ahead of
doctrine or strategy for understanding
it just one example in the 1950s but I
up if you look at the the history of in
the classic books like wizards of
Armageddon it describes about first
strike and second strike what he doesn't
tell you okay is that nobody recognized
these distinctions until actually than
when they after they had deployed
missiles it's only when the technology
is out there that the bureaucracy can
become aware and this takes this is
measured in years not months so we're in
a more dynamic volatile situation which
when I look back at the Cold War I'm
very thankful that it what it didn't go
off into a more extreme direction as I
believe it did not I'm much less assured
that this won't take off a negative
directions in a second nuclear eight
because I still have the floor that so I
could ask him follow up the follow-up is
well you said that you know we
underestimate the way in which
technology no can can drive change I
mean there are those who would argue
that one of the reasons why we got these
forecasts wrong and we overestimated the
pace of proliferation is that the people
who were making these estimates were
only looking at the technology we're
looking at the capability noticing for
instance you know countries like
Switzerland Sweden and so on could get
nuclear weapons if they wanted them what
was harder was forecasting the politics
you know the decision-making and not
just the capability have we gotten any
better at that and isn't that still a
crucial variable yeah i would say that
in the earlier excessively negative
forecasts of proliferation that we got
the politics wrong and the technology
wrong pakistan North Korea Iran Libya
the notion that they could have gone
nuclear and they were on McNamara's list
who the DoD study that was sent to the
White House and what happened there I
don't know the we greatly exaggerated
how easy it was to get fizzle material
for the 1960s 70s and even into the
1980s we also got the politics wrong but
i would say that we did not do a kind of
narrow a political technological
projection it was much worse than that
we got both of these things wrong so
have we gotten better at this I gotta
believe we have I mean the Iranian
nuclear weapon program has got to be the
most studied clandestine program nuclear
weapons program of any in history all
right so it doesn't mean we'll make the
right policy choices about it I guess
what surprises me is that we see this
thing coming and I'm just the debate in
Washington seems to me
so simplistic about an Iranian nuclear
weapon boiling everything down to two
possibilities the mullahs are crazy or
they're not they'd never they may
they're going to build these nuclear
weapons and they'll hit the button and
blow up Israel the first chance then you
get any buddy who's an Iranian expert
with any level of expertise or knowledge
even if they don't speak Farsi they say
no that's just not the way they operate
so then we revert to the other thing
there's nothing what are they going to
do with it because of deterrence I
suggest there's more than two options
two possibilities that could happen and
we need to explore those in detail
whatever ok I think Harrison is first
Chris okay house if could you take a
case and explain a little bit in a more
detailed way about how we would how you
would take a better understanding of a
concept like escalation and apply it to
the strategies and texts and tactics
that we use yeah okay give you a couple
thoughts on that let me emphasize here
that what I'm calling for is it changed
the framework I'm not trying to get in
to see the president to tell them what
to do about these things but that's a
different problem altogether okay on the
question about escalation I would say to
draw up a list like on the blackboard of
reasons for escalation which we haven't
done people look at escalation well why
would you worse in the crisis I can't so
and my response would be because you
don't have any other choice in other
words write a paper on counter
escalation as a response to the other
side's move all right if you were to
write a paper on counter escalation in
the Middle East today and it was 20
pages you would be the world expert on
it because you've given more thought to
it in one week on the Pentagon or CIA
has
another example de-escalation an
escalation are not the same things
because escalation you do damage to the
other side de-escalation you're coming
down and you you can lower the tensions
but you can't undo the damage if you've
launched some kind of strikes so that's
example number two to draw a distinction
between the dynamics of escalation and
the dynamics of de-escalation third how
to cross a threshold in a way that will
make sense to another country not just a
bunch of old white men sitting around a
room in Washington DC ok you want to
fourth okay fourth one is what sort of
conventions should we establish and what
are the major problems that we really
should be able to anticipate so you can
start a design of mechanisms which will
which would make this age safer than it
would otherwise be okay what I'm saying
is if you go back and you look at the
Cold War one of the reasons it turned
out well for us that we bought time and
nobody blew each other up was this
because there was a series of
conventions and understandings by the
two sides and i'm not talking about
confidence-building measures I'm talking
about lines which everybody understood
we were allowed to put air force bases
with nuclear weapons and ring the Soviet
Union they were not allowed to do that
to us okay when they did that we
considered their major escalation when
they put missiles into Cuba that was the
cause of the Cuban Missile Crisis in my
view all right but these asymmetries and
conventions were established by power
realities not ideal situations so if i
were a paper that is actually discussed
in my book is some ideas about the first
crisis of the second nuclear age and why
the when we look at that we should not
look at that from the point of view of
let's get out of the crisis
as soon as possible we should look at it
from the point of view of let's get out
of the crisis as soon as possible and
other frameworks such as what precedents
were setting we were very lucky in the
Cold War that the first crisis its first
crisis was the Berlin crisis of 1948
which was extraordinarily incremental
slow motion and controlled because there
was no direct shooting between the two
sides I don't know the answer to this
question but if some other country and
end country starts a nuclear crisis with
a US ally or just in general is the idea
to get out of this thing as soon as
possible or is it to use it as an
opportunity to make such a statement
that this would never be allowed again
and if we were trying to do that we
would escalate in a very different way I
thought Chris and then actually my
questions been answered okay yes if you
would speak to the microphone Thanks my
name is Hamid acepta and I'm from
Harvard University you thank you for
your presentation I enjoyed it you
mentioned earlier that in thinking about
Iran Washington is thinking that either
the mullahs are crazy or they're not
crazy within the context of whether or
not they may they make strike against
Israel um I've been hearing similar
arguments during the past a few weeks or
so and I can't help but think that is it
really isn't it really Washington that
is crazy not the more laws why why I say
this is because Israel is the one who's
had nuclear power for for a number of
years as you as you pointed out since
the
since late 70s or early 80s in fact it
was Washington that help Iran during the
time of the show to to come up with its
earlier plans but my point here is that
Israel is the one who's being the
aggressor in using its power to D the
nuclear eyes if you will Middle Eastern
powers such as Saddam Hussein such as
office of Assad and so on not Iran so is
it possible yeah and and and you made a
very interesting point by by suggesting
that you really like to see a change in
the framework do you mean a change in
the discourse of the framework or what
what do you really have in mind in
particular with respect to Iran and
Israel okay I would the answer to your
question is do I think Washington is
crazy the way it's been handling these
things yes okay i was watching c-span
the other day and a senior US government
official was on television giving a
press conference about israel and not
press a discussion and one of the think
unquote think tanks and was smirk it was
somebody in the audience asked the same
question why as the us-backed is allowed
israel to get nuclear weapons and there
was a smirk on his face I don't think
it's funny I mean I could see why he
thinks it's funny I'm not going to be
the first official of the US government
you're going to put into a corner and
get me to admit by accident that Israel
has nuclear weapons but I get this is so
dangerous what's building up and they
don't understand that it is dangerous
you know what because when they go into
work each day it isn't dangerous they've
never been stared into the face of
nuclear war for very interesting
generational reasons and they really
haven't thought deeply about what's
going on in terms of how bad things
could get I mean let me tell you a
missile crisis between Israel in Iran I
have gamed out many times for the US
government and it can get really really
bad in terms of wins and losses for our
ally without a shot being fired I i
decry this but I'm not in the business
of finger pointing I have to look at
this in a more constructive way and I
have to look to the future and we better
take seriously getting a missile crisis
which makes the Cuban Missile Crisis
pale in comparison between several
countries it's not the only problem with
a second if we read there's the whole
arms racing thing I can't find anybody
who recognizes the Israelis are going to
move there deterrent to see with all
kinds of implications and it sort of
reflects a lack of seriousness in my
bill I'm not the only one who thinks
this by the way how would I change the
framework the question is how do i
change the framework what I do is that I
write things I think you're raising a
larger question where is the locus of
discussion for productive conversations
and debate about these matters and
there's a list of where it the locus of
discussion could be or should be ok one
answer could be a new administration
comes in and understands these things
I've been around long enough to know
that if they haven't thought about this
before they get into office it's too
late so another answer is think tanks
maybe they should do it maybe university
should do it maybe journalists should do
it maybe other groups should do it and
maybe on that list is the way
unfortunately this is usually managed in
the
nited states all right and that is a
disaster hits and everybody is shocked
into sort of paying attention I have a
few questions please come up to the
microphone because we're live-streaming
this over the the internet so for the
sake of our Internet audience Thanks hi
I wanted to ask you if you could say a
little bit more about the new ways maybe
of delivering of your weapons are there
new innovations in this area and how
close are we doing this mythical
suitcase nuclear bomb quarter used by
terrorists yeah the question is uh how
are their new delivery mechanisms for
nuclear weapons there are in the sense
that that the end cunted proliferating
countries are now being able to put them
on missiles I mean there's a if you
looked at the data from the 40s and 50s
and you said what feature of nuclear
weapons changed faster than anything
else the answer is shrinking the physics
package that so I think that's not the
thrust of your question but they're
going to be able to put them on missiles
they will figure this out the suitcase
bomb we the United States had and the
Soviets had suitcase bombs and the Cold
War I don't really know how easy it is
to build these things I mean I physics
background a gun-type bomb should not be
that hard but to get to get access to
the engineering disciplines to put that
all together is quite a project there's
there's no doubt that a nation state
could be able to build a suitcase bomb
there's really there's I think little
doubt that they could do that and these
things are very difficult to detect for
reasons of physics and that is a danger
that sub-national groups will get these
I don't mean to minimize those dangers
we were chatting earlier and I give I've
been giving talks about this and people
say well I don't worry about Iran so
much its terrorist I worry about and we
don't get to chew
if it's Iran or terrorists we could get
both and increase suddenly the world
looks that way to me so you solve one
problem it doesn't make the other one go
away thank you for a stimulating
discussion one of the things that
crossed my mind during her discussion
was I'd like your opinion as to the one
of the reasons why the estimates might
have been way off base in terms of the
number of nuclear powers is that it it
seems to take an enemy to force a
country to think about developing
nuclear weapons now the three cases you
cited the three pairs of contestants so
to speak Indian Pakistan North Korea and
South Korea of the US or Japan and
Israel and Iran if you look at those
three situations in two of the cases
their historical well in almost all the
cases their historical grievances that
are driving this have you thought about
the possibility of having some
supranational mechanism monitoring it or
acquiring responsibility for it such as
the perm 5 UN Security Council and
here's here's one case that's very much
in the news today and that is the Korean
situation where you have the US and
China which are kind of in an
adversarial position with respect to the
Korean Peninsula in China's case in my
opinion looking past the danger of a
nuclear North Korea could pose or poses
for China what would it take for the US
and China to kind of coordinate their
diplomacy would it take a crisis or a or
if the US were to convey the message
that unless there is a joint effort that
basically we'll have to take matters
into our own hands because our security
is threatened if the North Koreans were
develop a missile that can see if we
reach our shores show you yeah speak to
that thank you sure that the u.s.
government under both admitted past
several administrations had as many
dialogues with China we even have an
official dialogue now called the
strategic dialogue which gets into this
why it is we tell them it's not in your
interest to have a nuclear North Korea
they agree and then nothing happens and
the same for Russia with respect to
nuclear Iran because that's not too cool
from their point of view and I have
thought about this and it seems to me I
mean I don't know what your impressions
of me already are but I actually think
there is great prospect for advancing
this as an idea in other words I think
what could happen is that a great power
arms control system replaces the NPT
system you describe the NP the NPT when
you said it would be the perm 5 that I
think you were using that as an
illustrative example there is and it's
and it's coincidental that the five
official nuclear powers legitimate
nuclear powers under the NPT are in the
perm 5 this brings up France and Britain
which to me it's it's so absurd that
they're in the permanent there in the
perm 5 given their power situation today
compared to 1945 but but I'll take what
I can get it seems to me that the
potential for a great power arms control
agreement really could increase sharply
if there is a spectacular nuclear
catastrophe involving these weapons and
that you might get an agreement which if
you looked at it today you would be
laughed out of the room as being a
starry-eyed illusionist but if some one
or two cities had just gone up and been
destroyed I can imagine the president
and the Chinese and the Russians sitting
down
saying look there's a lot in here that
you don't like sign it and they would I
can easily imagine that and I think the
situation is approaching a danger level
where that could actually happen not in
today's environment I really don't think
that's feasible but down the road and
much more there's much more thought
needs to be devoted to that in the early
80s I was a consultant to something
called the Catholics pastoral letter or
in war and peace which was the Catholic
Bishops statement that nuclear
deterrence was immoral but it was okay
if you used it on a temporary basis as
long as you use the time and energy so
you could get rid of nuclear weapons and
lessen your reliance on deterrence in my
view neither superpower did that there
are some efforts let's give credit where
credit is due the several US presidents
people don't realize seriously thought
of getting rid of nuclear weapons you
know from Harry Truman to Dwight
Eisenhower to Ronald Reagan to President
Obama this isn't entirely new
nonetheless it seems to me we should be
thinking about plans which would look
completely infeasible today from a
political point of view but wouldn't
after something happened
this is a question you asked earlier in
your talk why do we use this word
posture to describe a nuclear energy
chick posture it's you raise a good
subject which is why do we use the words
we use of which posture is one I don't
know the answer to that it's been around
for a long time but it didn't exist in
World War two it really exists it came
out of the RAND Corporation in the 1950s
is my sense in which you had to put
together a mixture of bombers missiles
and submarines and then that was
broadened to look at the interaction of
conventional forces with nuclear forces
all right today we have really not
looked at our our portfolio of forces in
anything like the systematic way we did
in the past although we could but the
there's a lot to be learned about why we
use the words we use and I would
encourage you to to look at the history
of these things it's a very good
question
I thank you so much for the talk my name
is Jeff from undergraduate across town
at Hunter College my question is I
noticed earlier you mentioned a nuclear
the Iranian nuclear weapons program as a
matter of fact as though it existed and
I was a little surprised that sitting in
the back but I didn't think I saw
anybody blink at that statement what
makes you think that that is in fact
there is in fact nuclear weapons program
in Iran are there a semi asymmetries of
information between us and you that
liking you to think that way kind of
nice I don't have any inside information
from my vintage odd to telling me that
you know how many he's planning on
building when I look at the totality of
evidence which is their secrecy their
history of lying about this and getting
caught doesn't seem to affect them much
and the hardening of their nuclear
infrastructure and the political
character of that regime and its view of
Israel and the United States and the
whole revolutionary ferment and my
belief i well I'm not I don't leave it
there I know whether the Shah had a
nuclear plans or not I don't know and I
don't think anybody else but when I look
at the totality of that information I'm
not saying that they have I have
definitive evidence that they do I think
looking at a problem like this in terms
of us legal standards of evidence or
scientific standards of proof and
publication in a peer journal is the
wrong way to look at it I think that's
where we might part company so you know
no I don't have the inside of
information but I think that's the wrong
way to do it that does open me and
people of my view two possibilities of
exaggerating things admitted when I look
at the evidence and the dangers I think
we have to consider scenarios where they
are building nuclear weapons and what
they would mean
um earlier you you said that the the
first crisis of the second nuclear age
would be extremely important you know
could be anyway and could even be useful
but haven't we already had the first
crisis I mean I think different people
maybe have different candidates but
wasn't the the Iraq war in effect you
know an effort said you know you might
say it was to create a crisis in order
to manage a crisis in order to get a cig
outcome yeah if err enough and this this
came up with in an earlier question
about exaggerated estimates that we did
we get the technology or wrong in the
politics politics wrong the technology
right I said no we got both wrong the
reason we the US government thought that
there was a bomber gap in a missile gap
in the 1950s isn't entirely our fault
it's the fault of a country which was a
closed hyper secret society called the
Soviet Union which wouldn't give out any
information the reason we went one of
the reasons we went to war against
Saddam Hussein is people really in the
government the US government thought
that he had weapons of mass destruction
and it was his secrecy in fact it's
fascinating i don't see why more isn't
made of this that he was playing a
double game he was signaling to iran
that he had WMD and to the US that he
didn't and I like this is interesting
because it's an illustrative of the kind
of dynamics that you not only can get
into in his case we did get into all
right I don't think the 911 attacks and
we could argue about this alone would
have gotten Congress to vote for a war
they had ad WMD to prevent this guy it
had to be staged as a preventive war
they didn't understand the difference
between pre-emptive and preemptive but
that's another subject but the I have a
chapter in my book called the first
nuclear age
and the lessons from it one of the other
powerful lessons is is every president
plead nuclear head games playing with
games with these things and I mean every
single president from Harry Truman
through the first George Bush all right
including any projeff k did this Jimmy
Carter authorized the most provocative
nuclear operations almost until that
point in time all right what does a head
game it's a feint to make the other side
think that you might actually not go to
nuclear war but escalate to intensify
the crisis using nuclear weapons now I
don't need you the historians have
uncovered most of this stuff when LBJ
went on TV to announce he was attacking
Hanoi and Haiphong Renault the air
strikes on North Vietnam in 1964 p-47s
with nuclear weapons were law instead of
torren Spain because we knew Soviet
spies were looking at these things and
they would report back you had Richard
Nixon even have what we has become to be
known as the madman nuclear alert to
convey to Moscow that he was so
irrational with nuclear weapons that if
they pushed him or they supplied North
Vietnam god only knows what he would do
all right now I would posit that the my
view of the Cold War and whether it is
or isn't like the second nuclear age
goes like this it's two points one the
two nuclear ages are more usefully
looked at together than differently
because each informs the other all right
and secondly there's lessons from the
first nuclear age that do or do not
apply to a second but if we don't know
what these lessons are we will never
pick them up in a second nuclear age my
I have a list of about 15 of these in
the book and the number one is
it is its broadcast out of the first
nuclear age and it's it goes like this
you don't need to detonate a nuclear
weapon to use it you don't need to
detonate a nuclear weapon to use it the
u.s. use nuclear weapons every single
day of the Cold War the US use nuclear
weapons to scare the Russians when we
were going to launch conventional air
strikes off of a carrier against North
Vietnam so I can see why we don't talk
about this history now but that doesn't
mean it didn't happen okay Judith did
you have a question do you mind coming
around this so hey bro can hear it okay
thanks thanks Chris okay judith miller
paula provocative if depressing talk
question what what are the implications
of the second nuclear age for the now
something which has been de-emphasized
which is missile defense I mean could we
once again reignite that and second of
all in terms of of lessons we have some
examples of countries that did walk up
to the nuclear precipice and back away
is there anything that could be applied
from that first nuclear age countries
that backed away to the second first
question dealing with missile defense is
let's see if I can freeze this as
precisely as I can i see i observe a
seat a ongoing change inside Washington
toward missile defense to being viewing
it as The provocateur Underminer of arms
control and we hate it to being
something that we may have to have four
very interesting reasons which we can
get into which is I remember
did alert a lot of work with Mac Bundy
after he left office and I always ask
him because I'm of the Vietnam
generation and when I went here this had
some impact on this campus but I asked
him why did you keep bombing the Ho Chi
Minh Trail when every one of your own
studies said it wasn't working and he
said you got to do something all right
and so I think we're initially attracted
to missile defense you may have seen
where the Iron Dome tests worked earlier
last week and this is to get the
short-range rockets we are really
putting money into into missile defense
it's it's still like the battle is just
beginning inside the Washington
bureaucracy and I'm not predicting how
it will turn out I do see changes on it
as two countries which have gone up to
the nuclear threshold or worse going
into it who's going up Libya Kazakhstan
was in it that's complicated case for
obvious reasons but then you have the
fascinating case of South Africa which I
think's intends to be overlooked and
there are other good historical examples
and I guess my view would be let's learn
what we can from them use whatever
insights we have because
non-proliferation izle is a lot better
than managing your way through a second
to clear age all right fewer nuclear
weapons all things considered is better
I can construct academic arguments why
that's not so but I don't believe them
it's like the argument that academics
construct about why the spread of the
bomb is a stabilizing effect okay I
maintain that the own the only people
who believe that are tenured social
science just probably at a handful of
Ivy League universities and University
of Chicago we have mutual friends
they're all right that's a question from
the audience
hi my name is that I I'm from Columbia
University well I come from Kazakhstan a
country in Central Asia that as you know
declared itself a nuclear free state
even though it has a sizable proportion
of the world's natural rhenium resources
and recently on the Nuclear Security
Summit in Washington in April President
Obama stated that Kazakhstan is a good
example to be followed what do you think
on this this year um I think he's
absolutely one hundred percent correct
that the both in in a rhetorical sense
that it's good for the United States as
an example but I think Kazakhstan is
much better off without nuclear weapons
for the good people of Cossacks then I
could well believe that the North Korean
citizens are would be much better off if
they didn't have nuclear weapons I have
run war games both at Yale and for the
government in the particular usually
looking on Iran and every time I play it
when I put the students in there and say
to you would you go nuclear if you face
the world that they faced they always go
nuclear all right so we don't seem to we
seem to have lost the capacity to put
ourselves in another person's position
which is really a very elemental thing
which I teach in a business school and
we all wasted ins in the business go
understand that that if you're in a
negotiation you got to look at it from
the other person's point of view and it
seems to have been a declining effect of
this but I absolutely think cusecs I
made the right choice and but is there a
possibility that other countries will do
the same there is always that
possibility and I could be completely
wrong here and the NPT could come back
as a universal organizer I don't I think
the evidence is so contrary to that that
even
of the future hasn't happened yet none
of us can know what the future will be
it is boy is it starting to be time
where we start considering the
management scenarios that I'm discussing
here tonight okay hi my name is Nicholas
Standish I'm a UH under graduate of
Columbia thanks for your talk my
question when you describe the second
nuclear age you just you mentioned that
Iran would have nuclear weapons in this
asian perhaps a terrorist group or two I
was wondering first it seems as if the
average American citizen or if you would
poll Americans they would overwhelmingly
say they're not comfortable with Iran
having weapons and definitely not with
the terrorist organization having
weapons so how would you propose if it's
necessary to deal with that reality how
would you propose to educate the sort of
American people on sort of how to look
at it in terms of escalation and not
containment as you've suggested yeah I
prefer the term dynamics rather than
escalation because it's it's a little
bit broader I it's a good I have not
thought as much about that as I should
have because I see my role as and others
as is going down this road and starting
this debate by writing and then the
government will what will the government
the government will start to study it
seriously or not so far I mean let's be
let's be let's be candid here that the
Pentagon is things that what I'm
describing or some significant parts of
the Pentagon that I'm absolutely correct
it's other parts of the government that
don't and I'm not even sure of that I
think what their attitude is it really
jeez I have no idea how to deal with
that I don't know what to do and I'm in
high position and I'm supposed to have
answers for things that I don't have so
it's not
that they reject what I'm saying as they
really don't know what to do about it
and they're sort of on this front effect
to observe the dynamics are really
interesting the because into it bent is
several administrations the the
intelligence people come in with all
this information about what's happening
and then after a while the recipients of
the intelligence information start to
get mad at them like what do you want me
to do and I've seen this in several
administrations and it's non Republican
and Democrat thankee the u.s.
bureaucratic SAR very much part of this
here but I'm not finger pointing and
saying that they're you know they're
there try they come into work they're
trying to do a good job hi dr. Bracken
Mickey Kaufman from Columbia University
you mentioned that in the first nuclear
age the symmetry of mutual deterrence
between the u.s. and the USSR was broken
most significantly by the asymmetry of
the power relations regarding the cuban
missile crisis that was what was okay
for the US was not necessarily okay for
the USSR looking at the second nuclear
age in a multiple symmetry or an ideal
state where you had a five-pointed
symmetry or nine pointed symmetry and
trying to avoid that nightmare scenario
where you have to come to what would you
described as an illusionary proposition
only being possible after a great
catastrophe could it be that the power
asymmetry that caused the risk of the
set of the first nuclear age could be a
problem in the second nuclear age and to
stave off the likelihood of such a
catastrophe we need to look at global
power power relations in general and ask
ourselves whether a unilateral American
power is in fact a greater risk than a
benefit these are really complicated
deep questions that we need more but I
need more help on I think the country
needs more help on i would encourage
people in this room raising a couple of
issues which let me just stick through
them one is what is the nature if any of
a US nuclear guarantee
I can't be the only one who has seen one
particular administration official
Secretary Clinton virtually say that the
US would extend a nuclear guarantee even
if the word nuclear wasn't used in it to
us allies in the Middle East and it was
striking to me oh that was the end of
the speech there wasn't a comment from
the White House like oh yeah where it's
a good idea or no we don't do it and so
one of the things we've learned in the
first nuclear age was you tell the
officials in the Pentagon and assistant
secretary said one comes to nuclear
weapons shut up coordinate it in a
central office or shut up and we have
seen have forgotten that lesson and you
could get really into the guarantees
that the US would make which we think
are strong but produce pathological
complications in an N player game one of
the greatest books of the 20th century
is called theory of games and economic
behavior by John a von Neumann and oskar
morgenstern and if one of the features
of that book anymore is people forget is
that if you if you have a game a number
of players and it goes up you get
completely different dynamics completely
different let me go back to the Cold War
you know everybody says the Cold War was
a to power blocked but it wasn't you had
after the 1964 you had five nuclear
powers I think yeah but they were
pretending that it was a two-block game
because it was a useful fiction for
stability purposes it meant that we
would hold them responsible for China
did we really think we could hold him
responsible for China no but it was
useful fiction to pretend like we could
you know I read these history sometimes
than they say that the u.s. thought it
was a model with the common
communist bloc so I went back and
started reading the New York Times for
1964 1965 you can do it all right it was
completely understood in Washington that
there was a fissure in the communist
bloc by 1964 completely understood at
the RAND Corporation State Department
everybody understood it yet it was a
useful fiction this leads me to search
for other useful fictions for enemies
and as I said earlier this thing like
nuclear Allies could really give us a
lot of problem I don't want to mention
any countries but just as Pakistan could
cause China a lot of problem but it's
very evocative I mean I was thinking
about this the other day about the like
the advance of conventional weapons in
say groups like Hezbollah and Hamas if
they get them it's not that they need
nuclear weapons I mean if they can reach
deep into Israel with cluster bomb
warheads and Iran has a nuclear
deterrent you can get into some really
bad scenarios but that's happened before
I mean that's how the north Kim
il-sung's attack in 1950 was viewed in
Washington as we knew he didn't have
nuclear weapons but we thought he was
the cat's paw for Stalin and Mao and
there's new research indicating well
people here were probably more expert at
that than I am so these sort of
three-way games existed even back then
and even the Cuban Missile Crisis was a
three-way game with Castro but it was
useful to pretend that it wasn't okay I
see this question in the back
I'm just wondering if you could
elaborate more on your discussion on
cyber security what exactly is a
relationship between cyber security and
disarmament and what would you consider
a cyberattack and if you have any
thoughts on what the international
community should do to prepare for right
my sense of the cyber warfare issue is
that we have created a cyber warfare
community and command in the United
States and that we don't look at this in
a broader holistic way okay technology
advances then and now because of
synergies between different systems so
when used in the 50s when you started to
shrink the physics package for a
hydrogen bomb and then you had the
invention of inertial navigation systems
for warheads and advances in missile
propulsion it was the convergence of
these three technologies that
dramatically changed the whole dynamic
at a techno-economic level politics was
very important still not saying it
wasn't we are in an age at least as
revolutionary as the 1950s when you it
takes iber warfare financial warfare
precision strike nuclear warhead design
and there's one other I can't think of
at the moment but if you need it out to
my notes here and so it's the synergies
between these things when I teach at
Yale I locked up go at three thirty
thousand feet and then come down to
ground level cyber warfare could be very
important as a weapon to stun blind or
paralyzed an enemy command system while
there was time for incoming missiles to
finish it off and kill the missiles of
the other side
and it strikes me if I'm the first
person to think about that I'm sure
others have thought about it but not I
haven't seen any papers written on it
that the in other words the role of
cyber attack for blinding command and
control systems or command structure
attacks to to dis you know to destroy
them it's a strikes me as a not
advocating it we better understand this
as far as stopping this I just other I
don't really have any good ideas on that
because it's done at a decentralized
level to the extent government's control
it at all apparently i just wish that we
would be broadened out and put into a
more integrated systems analysis
framework to better evaluate its true
consequences on regional stability
earlier you said that if there if there
were an exchange of nuclear weapons if
one or two cities were destroyed that
you might actually see a great power
arms control system complies well can
you describe what such a system might
look like yeah my work not I haven't
flushed at all all of the details but
one of the arguments I either lost or
didn't get as far as losing because
nobody paid any attention to it was in
the recent talking to people in
Washington about the Nuclear Posture
review I'm a big proponent of no first
use of nuclear weapons and China has
declared no first use of nuclear weapons
India has declared Russia has not France
and Britain have not but I figure we
could lean on Francis or at least
Britain and get them to do this and so
anything that could start establishing
norms among major powers who possess
nuclear weapons not letting in like in
north korea declared no first use i
wouldn't acknowledge it as a serious
proposal but i would start
building conventions and norms that
stitched together the major powers
because the discussions as I understand
them about nuclear weapons between the
United States and the major powers today
are pretty much us hanging them to join
a us-led sanctions team which I wish
they would but there seems to me they're
not going to do it so if the US would
declare no first use of nuclear weapons
now we put us in conformance with other
major powers who have the bomb to say
that it was I mean what's the reaction I
got about this with his argument I
didn't think anybody understood what I
was talking about I think the people
that I spoke to in Washington are
involved with this we're looking at
what's going to be in the paper we sent
over to state next week and the
interagency review the the capacity to
think about long-term consequences of
current decisions was what my bias is
you know and you you risk as you get
older thinking this and i also gatos
smith says it's okay to have a professor
we both know what Yale it's okay that
biases if they tell you what you what
you are but my biases are that the level
of discussion on these things has gone
really downhill you know about arms
control not just ratted okay this is
probably going to be the last question
so please come to the microphone yes
please yeah thank you I just thought of
something else because actually
yesterday ratio passed the biggest the
defense budget that they ever had which
is like two trillion rubles or something
like this but what I thought about was
that I thought about the you know right
now we're in a situation where we are
running out of oil and so people are
turning towards nuclear power
essentially for energy use and
Russia is one of the biggest countries
that specializes in promoting themselves
as providers of nuclear power plants and
actually they recently bought the
uranium deposits in Canada and
previously they try to buy them in the
United States so they are truly a great
power in and they are proposing to all
the different countries in Europe that
they'll build nuclear power plants for
them so we have the situation which is
the combination of you know energy and
maybe maybe nuclear proliferation
because I think that wants to you know
they are building these nuclear power
plants all over the place they are
increasing capability for it safe when
I'm proliferation no big huge problem
because it looks like nuclear power will
increase dramatically for obvious
reasons and the this means more physical
material in the world which has got to
be protected and it's a very very big
problem I believe some that my sense is
the US government is is not only well
aware of this is is actually taking good
planning steps to make sure that that we
will fund a lot of the protective
measures or storage measures but it
clearly is not going to affect Iran or
North Korea who my view will not allow
storage of their physical material
outside of the country for rather
obvious reasons we might not give it
back all right I think we're just about
out of time I just want to mention
something I think many of you know many
of you are participants in the research
component of this summer program this
nuclear summer and I ask you all the
stay tuned because we have students who
are working on many of the questions and
the problems that that came up tonight
about you know why Kazakhstan gave up
its nuclear weapons you know what kind
of nuclear program was the Shah trying
to create why also you know other
countries like Brazil and Argentina we
have a student right now in Rio de
Janeiro doing resource and why Brazil
decided to discontinue its nuclear
program so we're going to be presenting
that research making
accessible so I urge you all continue if
you haven't already to to look at our
website for the heard talk a little
strategy initiative so let me before I
thank Paul Brackenfur coming let me just
also thank Roger hertog for making all
this possible let me thank seat before
providing this great space yarnold
Saltzman Institute for organizing this
lecture series with this so thank you
Paul Bracken thanks for coming thank you
very much delighted thank you very much
you